dreams are keeping me away
[Music]
I think of what the world could be a
vision of the one I see a million dreams
is all it's gonna take
Chickie's million dreams you'll find out
later why we have this song stuck in our
head it's part of my celebratory wonder
okay so the Beckley feels here do you
celebrate and to to support his hangs me
chat celebrate good I think he feels
responsible for love with some of your
followers he gave his fans and they come
to me for premium content of the Tigs
and they get it every single time he's
such a good boy he's in such high
spirits today so hopefully he won't
cause us much trouble I think he's in
huh yeah
what okay let me try that again
I think he's in high spirits today
because of something dramatic that
happened yesterday I'm like I look like
an [ __ ] like yesterday I'm get to
Asia her be like talking about this
wonderful day care he's only had two
accidents since being home like that's
what I get for talking like that because
I took the O to his hairstylist and it's
also a daycare so like he loves it he
gets to play with the other dogs so I
thought I go to pick him up and
literally he comes up the stairs and
he's like hysterically crying to see me
and I'm like hmm that's weird like even
when we went to Turks and Caicos we were
gone for 10 days he didn't even care to
see me like when he got home like why is
he crying yeah why you could I miss Tia
why you cry so then we got home and he
literally like takes a huge piss a [ __ ]
and throws up on in the kitchen what the
hell did they do to him at that place oh
I call actually
I didn't call been called cuz I'm like
afraid of that stuff called gave them a
piece of my mind so he will never be
going back there and now he's coming to
work with us exactly no he's our newest
intern Leo stopper nepotism wins always
always a big fan of nepotism ever since
watching dynasty like I'd only known
episode Chad so I don't know what
happens but it's a lot of episode I'm
still really pissed off about that she
didn't get CLO Fallon she so deserved it
she really really did just keep watching
you going to show that you guys it's on
Netflix and I think you would all really
enjoy it and then we can all once you're
done with it and then we'll we'll give
the toaster
like a weekend or two to catch up and
then we'll like go through it and it's
just something I've been sitting on I'm
so excited to talk about it me too
anyways we have some some interesting
stories for you tonight yeah it's funny
again yesterday we said you know it's
funny I would do the show every day and
there's still content like the next day
to talk about and then today there's
like nothing there's always five but I
pulled five it was like pulling teeth
but I got them and it's it's a whirlwind
there's two bachelor related stories two
royal wedding related stories and then
an aviation related story no it's more
of like a cosmopolitan world news story
that fifth one it's definitely world
news yeah
so let's jump right in I'm Claudia sure
a girl with no job I'm Jackie I show you
jacking up problems and I don't need to
pimp myself out because I hit 100k last
night this is the morning toast we're
gonna give you the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast this is also our last episode of
the week and I'm sure that makes you
guys really sad but it makes me really
happy are we not doing up podcasts oh I
guess I want to make sense yeah no but
we could do a podcast tomorrow if we
feel like if we know we'll do a pockets
tomorrow if there's news that needs to
be broken broken if it's a day like
today there will be no podcast I think
that's very there okay first up this is
a story we didn't want to talk about but
I have a rule once 100 people tagged me
in something we have to talk about it
totally because personally I don't care
but you guys do so new bachelor couple
as she I and Jared hi bone see put quote
potential life partners in each other
okay you guys this is pretty shocking
because what's more shocking about it is
that they're really still 45 minute
video like about their relationship and
like People magazine is promoting it
this propaganda film like yeah oh my god
it's totally propagated
it's really it's they made it themselves
like self-promotion oh they didn't make
it themselves it's a part of a serious
club story of us that she that she
hosted I think last year no really like
YouTube channel no it's not for herself
really let me check let me check whose
YouTube channel was it on I was just
watching it we were I'm Ashley eyes are
you sure it's on her Channel watching
it's a 45-minute video we got through I
think ten minutes where they're just
talking about how like their first
impressions of each other on TV blah
blah blah like all the stuff no it's a
kinetic TV okay so this video was for is
this a sponsored oh no no again if this
video is like a series that they did
last year that she just hosted okay and
so now she's in her own relationship so
and she
like she was able to use the same title
and everything trademark wise like we're
good it's still for kinetic TV okay so
she getting paid tip to make this idiom
probably good for her okay I want to go
take you through the details because
they have announced that they are
together quote there's just this
undeniable magnetic force between the
two of us that just is indescribable
I've been told people shortly after
kissing his girlfriend for the cameras
on the nylon young Hollywood party red
carpet they stepped out together the
other night and then they they put out
this this short film okay they said
quote love Concord okay love conquer at
all don't get me wrong I love love like
I'm in love I love love I just hate when
people like make it out to you more than
it is like at the end of the day there's
no magnetic field between you two like
you just like each other yeah and if
there was a magnetic field like you've
known each other for like four years now
the magnetic field isn't just this is
hot side and Prejudice no but I am I do
love love and I'm happy for them and you
know after years of Tears I'm
embarrassing her on television he's
finally made it right and they can be in
love and best friends and like honestly
I want nothing but for them to be happy
I don't have anything negative to say
about either of them it's just like it's
I don't know and I don't know that I'm
I'm not like sold like the rest of you
who are so happy about it no I'm happy
like maybe we like won't see Ashley I'm
bats from Paradise crying anymore it's
like that's a good thing but they'll
have a TV wedding if they get married
look I wonder how long they've been
dating for because people were saying
they saw them making out at Coachella he
says that he really like fell for her in
October of this year
no it's last year yeah like like six
months ago right that's a long time yeah
maybe they'll get engaged soon cuz like
in bachelor world that's like six months
is like ten years yeah approximately
yeah for sure so he's just running
around the set like having the time of
his life he'll what to help you hang
around away he's being he's being a bad
boy no here's some ways well he's being
a bad boy you guys it's being taken care
of it's it's being handled give me ball
yeah okay Ashley I and Jared these are
some money quotes that people chose to
highlight for us okay quote she makes me
watch say yes to the dress but that's
okay I don't mind says hi bon I wonder
say watched your episode
Jackie you took the words right
today our episode was on the day before
and the day of the world waiting so
that's what they associate or I'll make
sense they're not wrong at least they're
insurance with some things that are
necessary what else have they said he
said he's the boyfriend who watches say
yes to the dressing rubs my back but
then again I go see Avengers and
Deadpool with him that being said I kind
of fell asleep on his lap during those
movies the two are so comfortable
together it's not it's hard not to
imagine them spending their future
together when asked if they have talked
about marriage the couple was open about
the fact that they've definitely
considered their future but are happily
enjoying their dating life right now
quote as soon as we started dating we
both knew that this isn't just for us to
date his boyfriend/girlfriend
this was more this was more so we were
going to date because we see a potential
life partner in each other high bun said
we've talked about it but we're just
dating right now we're enjoying that we
literally just announced our
relationship the thing is we've been so
close for the past three years I just
don't I just know her inside and out I
know everything about Ashley that's
definitely true there's no secrets
between these jokes like how long could
they date you know
yeah I don't know I definitely I think
it makes sense me because also like he
seems like kind of like a shy guy and
she's very outgoing and I think for
those reasons they make sense and like
he's had three years of like post
bachelor Fame like it's worn off nobody
settling down into his new life in LA
and like this just is the next logical
step but here's the thing like when he
went on paradise like he was like the
cool hot guy I don't think in his whole
life he's ever been that guy I don't
think he's hot first of all but like in
paradise he was like the jock like he
was like the cool hot like and like I
think he like that probably got to his
head and he didn't need to like date
astray because there was more options
for him but now that he's like back to
reality where he's just like a regular
restaurant manager he's fine
it's he regular restaurant manager so
that's what his job was oh I don't know
I'm gonna venture out and say now no now
there's just like influencers and you
know they work in the same field right
they go to events together yeah anything
that's exactly what they do so it makes
sense and you know as people who support
things that make sense we're gonna
support this one yes I do i do prefer
when things make sense but these days
who knows they also like things are out
here making no sense
that's true but TM ya know it's time for
their their relationships to evolve both
of them they both needed a significant
other there's
just like makes sense you know TM TM
what no just let it go
Oh trademark trademark yeah let's do not
forget we made that up much like a lot
of other things okay anyways do you have
any additional thoughts on these - no
come here less I just like now it's like
the third stream is just gonna keep on
chugging I know and while I'm happy for
them you know because this relationship
has added probably a year of gas to the
thirst train and probably like like half
a million dollars into their pocket
exists in total in sponsorships and now
another couple sponsorship and they'll
do like when they get engaged and then
they'll do their TV wedding and then
like baby like this is like Jade and
Tanner part two it's like just as gene
and Tanner we're like but JD Tanner are
so happy with what they have because
they have like a life in Kansas City
that doesn't require much but if they're
trying to live the big life in LA like -
Bella's not gonna cut it
that's true Jay and Tanner are really
like her they set the standard for all
bachelor couples it's like the best way
to do ads the best way to like have a
real like to go better around like your
money
yeah like the best way like Tanner like
does ads but he's still like works for
Toyota like Chevrolet no I'm gonna hi
Andy
how do you pronounce it out without
Hyundai what's wrong with you today
there's a why but its Hyundai its kind
of touch are you hey I only have a
license I only see I've never got into
the Hyundai dealership you guys you know
what's so weird it's like a couple years
ago Margo confessed something to us this
is so interesting so like we don't drive
because we grew up in the city we don't
Jackie doesn't member license I Drive
because Ben drives but there's like a
whole world of cars that like we kind of
missed out on and when we were like just
like out to lunch or something Margo
like confess to us our sister she was
like I don't know what like car symbols
like are of which brands like you know
like that says Oh Sadie's she didn't
know that that was Mercedes she didn't
know if she didn't know a chat like she
didn't know right she's a yoga
corresponding logos with brands like for
cars when it's like you see a car
passing and it has an H you know it's a
Honda you know yeah or if it's like a
slanted H it's a Hyundai but if it's
that weird symbol it's a Toyota not
always aware she definitely knows what
Toyota and Honda yeah but it's just like
funny how like that's just like a
cultural thing yeah I mean I know what
Mercedes
is from mrs. Doubtfire yes when he
plucks with the emblem off the car this
was 11 by fruiting oh man okay next
story is also back to a related story
the bachelorettes Becca kufran is
already engaged quote it was the
happiest moment of my life
okay so People magazine was out here
thirsting for bachelor khon kaen
yesterday and they posted like the first
official photo of Becca foo furan you
know I'll take a close-up so this on our
Instagram I will take a close-up right
now um begrudgingly because you need to
see that this is Becca conferring or is
it Adriana from where is it literally
like anyone else no it's like when I saw
this picture someone was like Becca and
I was like I had to go to people myself
to know when I was permanent they were
trying to pass this off as back this
picture looks more like me than it does
Becca no totally thank you for the
close-up like what has changed first
don't like the makeup first of all like
the makeup is bad and it's really heavy
and I don't think she was ever a girl
who wore a lot of makeup but okay which
by the way I was actually thinking about
this morning like on absolutely no level
can I relate to any girl who doesn't
wear makeup like last night I was at
like a charity gala and I got this new
lip gloss and I was like showing a
temperance I was like really excited
about it and my friend Layla she was
like can I put it on you should I guess
sure like I'd like never wear lip gloss
or like anything and I was just like how
do I mean ya know how I can't relate to
people who like never wear like lipstick
I never just like walk out of my house
without like a little pigment no
lipstick I kind of understand because
some people like don't want to draw
attention to the fact that they have
small lips or but then also some
people's lip color like he's naturally
really big like Margo LuAnn like doesn't
ever need to really listen anything I
can't relate to people who go out
without like bronzer or anything on
their skin like how brave are you know
what I can't relate to I can't relate to
people who wear nothing on no makeup
except for eyeliner like and they're
fighting I don't know who does up a
that's just that's literally Dana yes
it's of disgust when I see someone like
that I'm like oh you don't shower no
it's not about showering it's like okay
if you're just gonna do one makeup step
like it can't be just eyeliner that
makes
no sense so if any of you are doing that
no that was definitely tiny area than
one make up seven you want a jar
attention to your eyes adjusting mascara
then there was simply a period in my
life where I did that with like
under-eye eyeliner but like I wasn't
being I wasn't good yeah like please
Dean is still in seventh grade yeah
she's like a totally a seventh grader
yeah I don't know what movie to equate
it to but it's like she stopped maturing
after seventh grade saying even when
she's in the car and she has music on
she like rolls down on the whip all the
windows in black as you go to know like
she just got like a car in high school
love you Dana um anyway so Becca
announced that she's engaged which is
exciting and like obviously um you know
what's so interesting though that guy
who was dating Ali Grayson is on her
season Colton what yes he's gonna win I
don't think he wins and I think he'll be
the bachelor because we need a celebrity
bachelor oh and this is the only way to
do it
wait I'm Chuck pour le Raisman she's so
much better than that
wait the bath sir like never ceases to
amaze me in the thirsty thanks people in
the NFL he's no longer in it he was the
one that Sean Johnston gymnasts husband
set Aly Raisman up with oh my god they
set them up I just started to following
Sean Johnson and her husband Andrew East
on Instagram and they're like
influencers and they share their whole
life on YouTube and they're so damn cute
its head I'm trying to get home to us oh
yay um so I'm shook that he's on that
he's gonna subject himself to this but I
think he'll definitely need the bachelor
because we need an eligible bachelor
with it right cuz he's retired so maybe
he's not the bachelor no but like
obviously Becca gets engaged like I
would just love for one time for someone
to not get engaged and be like hey I
really like you well it's not gonna be
backup because like she wasn't he she's
sorry she's a codependent woman exactly
but she was engaged to Ari so it's not
like she like left that to go like date
I'm having like a major internal
struggle about this because like there
is not one part of me that has any
interest in watching this season of The
Bachelor but the nature of my job like I
just think is like oh I agree
I was talking to Stan about it yesterday
it's like I'm not interested in the
season of The Bachelor but we have and
then to watch Oh much work like but like
the job to be about sort of like a
full-time I should get benefits well I
was really into the bachelor my Monday
nights would be like bachelor like I
would watch with friends like
wine it was a whole ordeal now like I'll
do whatever the [ __ ] I want on a Monday
night and I'll watch The Bachelor house
I'm falling asleep like that's the most
I can do for you guys are you gonna look
at spoilers so I've looked at spoilers
for Lauren B and I was like really like
shocked
Lauren Bushnell yeah Bushnell then I got
Lauren but actually they're also that
Lauren B because I was in the I was like
I was like 3/4 of the way done with our
season I'm like I can't bear this
anymore just [ __ ] tell me so the fact
that like you can find out it's like
makes it really like why don't you just
want to find out but I've always been
disappointed in the fact that like I
found out so I'm gonna do my best not to
I didn't know Rachel and Peter and like
I was on the edge of my seat till the
very end
yeah well I I feel like I'm not gonna
look at spoilers because I don't want it
to hinder how we talk about it on this
show like you know someone wins I'll
either be like oh I see something
between you know and I just I want to be
wrong or I want to be right also I'm
gonna I'm gonna do a bracket so I kind
of can't look at spoilers I like have
been every night before bed watching
Planet Earth - have you seen it ok so
they released his second version the
first one they did was like
revolutionary and it was like 10 years
ago so they did a second version and it
was incredible so I've just been
watching it every night and I feel like
I'm learning so much about like our
earth our creature isn't like I just
can't go back to watching The Bachelor
do you know II mean I'm like I'm so
above it right now wait good
Attenborough that British guy who
narrates everything like I just I can't
do you don't need me yeah I'm so much
more like intellectually sound than The
Bachelor like it would be a huge step
down for me and I'm really working on my
brain and I just don't think it would
help you know I have like brain problems
yeah you you need to get this app that I
have that has like brain tricks
what's a cold I don't know I saw and
like an ad for it on Instagram and I
actually got lucky I saw too but I
thought it let me see if I deleted it I
don't know I think I might've Julie did
say we're sending me like a lot of
annoying people brain games Lumosity
that's it it's really good daily Brandt
brain games yes so um we must remind you
that this show is a no spoiler zone if
you spoil [ __ ] in the comments you get
blocked if you spoil [ __ ] in the morning
toasters group you will get blocked if
you spoil [ __ ] on my Instagram or
Claudia's are the toast Instagram and
the DMS you will get oh yeah I had been
soo maldis ruined for me
by a lovely girl named Madison in the
DMS and she got put on lust and she was
not happy about it yeah you'll get put
on glass don't be Madison don't be a
Madison you guys look at the oh I know
we're not supposed to talk about we're
not supposed to talk about things in
which you can't see but Theo is finally
being a good boy he's dead asleep and he
looks so damn cute um but at least the
first episode of The Bachelor is like
jam-packed with like yes so there's a
way to get you like into it through like
the subsequent like three or four
episodes where they do all those group
dates are [ __ ] terrible Oh what
really like is hiring about the show is
that like you learn about all these
people you try so hard to keep up with
who people are cuz like oh that's the
chicken enthusiast oh that's the dentist
like oh that's the girl with the blonde
hair it's so hard to keep up with people
like who they are what their name is and
what their job it's like to remember
them so it's like I put in all this time
and effort and then I just get nothing
out of it and like it's just like I need
to like we need to collectively stop
watching like I need everyone keep
watching so don't have FOMO I agree also
do you want to know one of the
contestants is already on cameo someone
put them in the toaster house like when
like so someone that one of the
contestants show hasn't even aired yet
is try and like make money on cameo
that's literally the definition of
thirst no survivor when you look up
first in the dictionary you see this
guy's cameo page we should have like a
proclamation of like all the phrases we
coined do you know what I mean no one
gets it twisted yeah cuz like what's
ours
there's monster general that's us
protect me some Ramsey at all costs
protect blank at all costs um things
that make sense yeah what else
treacherous treacherous we just we need
like a constitution of sorts a bill of
rights okay do you want to take care of
that sure this X story I'm like kind of
obsessed with its back to the Marco
sparkle you guys because she's parkland
17 royal rules Megan Marco has to follow
now that she's a duchess okay there's no
Sophie's there so interesting one no
selfies during her first official event
with Prince Harry Megan revealed that
she would no longer be able to take
selfies with fans after a couple asked
her to pose quote were not allowed to do
selfies she told the duo the role was
created to encourage people to make eye
to eye contact and make conversation
with Royals instead of turning their
back
to them it's a little security thing
like you can't be getting so close to
random people yeah - no autographs she
may have some suits super fans in her
past but these days the new Royal isn't
allowed to sign autographs under any
circumstances from here on out it's only
on Royal documents and in some rare
cases visitors books I guess it's so
like people can't copy thank you three
no social media she's not allowed to
have her own social media but he didn't
she it's like a phone where she was like
a fake and sorry I'm just like keep up
like you can't go from being someone who
was like completely immersed in like the
culture tech world from due to being a
royal who's not allowed to have any
access to the outside world like Harry
was born with it Harry never had a phone
like he would he never had an Instagram
she did she had a blog yeah so she
definitely has like a burner phone that
she just uses like she has one fake
Instagram account yeah perhaps I don't
know I don't know if the Queen like
allows Finster's that's not really on
the docket yet no she told the house to
for no dark nails huh that makes seven
five no traveling without morning
clothes so like morning like in morning
look black yeah because ever since the
King George died while then Princess
Elizabeth and Prince Philip were in
Africa and had to travel back to England
and regular clothes it is imperative
that all Royals always travel with a set
of funeral clothes in order to be
respectful I was like so sad totally
fatalist always ready for someone to die
I mean honestly that's how I think I'm
always like ready for someone to just
drop dead but in the crown like it
really was a huge deal she was in Africa
with the Prince they like the whole
world knew that her dad died before she
did because she was like in a remote
location
oh but like that couldn't even happen
today because of phones so like that's
maybe it's like an obsolete role no but
then still she just had to get on the
plane and and go home but she showed up
in her in her vacation or Africa writer
six curtsy time the Queen expects female
family members including Kate Middleton
and Camilla parker-bowles
to curtsy when they enter a room in her
presence even when it's an informal
occasion which means Megan better get
used to the curtsy we were debating that
on this show we were yeah you were
saying that so-and-so doesn't have to
curtsy to the Queen never said that yes
you did I like this isn't brand new
information to me I'm pretty sure Chucky
I swear on my life you guys does anyone
remember maybe like I'm making
I didn't say that claudia was saying
there's no way she is to curtsy to the
Queen but I don't think that so why
would I say that I don't know you said
it in public I was you know conversation
will exact no or we were talking about
now not Megan but likes just someone ran
them that like doesn't always have to
concede never spoken about curtseying
because if I'm said bow no if we did we
would talk about how we use stuff to
curtsy at our piano recitals okay but I
definitely said bow and I'm gonna wait
for a toaster to back me up or toasters
I literally never said that maybe if she
did know it and I swear okay seven no
miniskirts the Queen disapproves autumn
lines higher than an inch or two above
the knee that's just like high school so
does the Queen also disapprove of any
even hemlines because Megan can't seem
to do that
eight none of that cross-legged business
it's frowned upon for royal members to
cross their legs according to an expert
for hello you'll never see Kate
Middleton crossing her legs anywhere
other than at her angles I think they
mean ankles but he says coil right now
and you're not no I could never be over
a member of the royal family because I
crossed my legs and I cross my legs
sitting on my own couch hi my legs
driver cross my legs oh my god my legs
are oh I crossed my legs sitting in an
uber
Maggie legs are never uncrossed it's so
uncomfortable I don't know he's just
they probably each other up like they're
ready you know I'm I like crossing my
ankles and that's it I honestly prefer
to say like this and if it were ladylike
and approval it just jagged as the queen
of this is your legs on cause it's
actually that's it's like a common
misconception it's actually not why not
because you could see your vagina no you
can't it's just a it can leave the room
if you're in a dress yeah that I feel
bad but then if your hemline is
appropriate you really can't be then
right I know so if you're just sitting
like with your legs down like in a dress
to you could see up it I don't know
there's no there's no winning eight I'm
sorry nine no wedges the Queen
apparently despises wedge shoes says
Vanity Fair so she has to get rid of
them I totally totally agree you like a
big clot alert like for a while like
when I was in like the seventh grade and
I got these wedges from Steve Madden
with the habit the zippers it was like
the best day of my life like then they
were cool like it's 2018 we can do
better than wedges wedgies are just
they're so like you just a big towering
like galoot and like us there's nothing
sleeker than just like a stiletto so
Queen I'm on your side you know what I
have to say to that yes Queen ten
mealtime is at 8:30 a.m. p.m. if dining
is yeah dinner if dining the Queen
Meghan should be prepared to always eat
at 8:30 and Jenny if the Queen does his
article half a million typos oh yeah or
did you [ __ ] no no no it's dining the
Queen who or this article held on we're
gonna publicly shame meg swert lo no I
don't want her name I wanted the
publication a news you just slandered a
girl before noon that's another one of
our phrases I'm sorry Meg that's another
one of our phrases slandering someone
his articles so informative and thank
you for writing it Meg so yeah keep
going okay John the Queen if you die
with the Queen you're eating at e3 and
dinner will be over by 10:00 the Queen
is known for strictly adhering to her
royal schedule yeah ten o'clock is a
late time for an old lady beating to be
eaten dinner she definitely don't eat
shirts she definitely like me has she
has two dinners no one at six o'clock
and then 8:30 yeah I had the weirdest
dinner last night what you have well I
started off with some tasty delight and
then grilled chicken and brown rice
it was just like weird that sounds just
like I was art dependent so full you're
a dessert then dinner but then I went to
a charity gala which had like kosher
meat I'd had like some tacos here's
three dinners ya know like two dinners
and a dessert yeah okay no open seating
at a royal family gathering Meghan will
always be sat next to Prince Harry well
duh twelve no room rating there's a
strict code of conduct for how to enter
a room when you are with the Royals
here's the royal order Queen Elizabeth
Prince Philip Prince Charles Camilla
Prince William Kate Middleton and the
most likely Harry and Megan so she's
lost yeah but I thought the Queen's
always lost
it went entry wait why would she have to
wait for other people totally thirteen
don't eat before the Queen or after the
Queen Margot should not begin eating her
meal until after the Queen has started
hers the former suit star also needs to
keep her eyes peeled for when the Queen
stops eating everyone must stop eating
even if there is still food this sounds
and although they're living in the
palace with the Queen so they're having
dinner together
William live with the Queen - I don't
think so
no I think they have say the family they
got to move out - quite still living
with her grandparents bro 14 no sleep if
she lives with her grandparents she's
too young for you bro
14 no sleeping till the Queen sleeps you
know who else lives with their
grandparents let me think I don't know
Mason Ramsay totally so and he's not
allowed to go to bed force grandparents
either no sleeping until the Queen's
leave but how do you know what if she's
having trouble sleeping she tends to I
know I'm not asleep yet
stay awake no it's like when she goes in
to prepare I can go in a Margo stays at
the Queen's House she's got to stay up
until queen elizabeth ii falls asleep
they call her qe2 in this article that's
like the boat so says regular boat that
Lindsay Lohan's parents met on the
Parent Trap - qe2 the Queen Elizabeth
yeah apparently it's considered bad form
to call it a night before the monarch
luckily the queen isn't known for
throwing all night readers so Markel
likely will be able to hit the hay
before midnight
next up do not pass go monopoly is not
allowed according to The Reader's Digest
the Leeds Building Society gave the Duke
of York Prince Andrew the monopoly to
which she responded quote we're not
allowed to play Monopoly at home it gets
too vicious that is crazy that is
clickbait if I've ever heard of 16 no
pinkies out tea time is an important
time for the Royals etiquette expert
told people that the correct way to
drink tea is to use your thumb and index
finger to hold the top of the handle
while the middle finger supports the
bottom you should also sip from the same
spot the entire time so the rim doesn't
get lipstick stains oh my god that's
literally me but then once I get a
lipstick C and I go to a fresh spot with
that I like rub an old lipstick saying
over saying if you are a coffee drinker
you should loop your index finger
through the handle but beware no pinkies
out even the Royals draw the line
somewhere
Wow the 17th and final rule no shellfish
for you it's an ancient royal tradition
to stay kosher to say no to shellfish in
order to avoid food poisoning while the
royal family doesn't always head here to
that rule Queen Elizabeth still does
let's be honest the 92 year old loves
her traditions and also she's 92 and
healthier than all of us yeah maybe we
could all stand to be cutting our
shellfish since it's only a few days and
it's still unclear if Megan will be
allowed to eat the feast on the
exoskeleton barring aquatic
invertebrates
now that she's no longer a mere mortal
sorry she's still mortal totally but
perchance she may be reminded she always
needs funeral clothes with her
yeah but perchance she's already thrown
out her hunger from molest crustaceans
and echinoderms along with those
godforsaken wedges and of course there
are more but I guess those are the 17 he
has access that is so crazy
also I read that yesterday in the
Telegraph that because we're always like
why does the queen of a persuade its
queen of a purse know when I found out
the queen is a purse because she uses it
to send messages to her security so
apparently if she puts her purse on the
table I mean she's not having a good
time she puts her purse on the floor it
means she wants to go home and it's just
like if The Telegraph is telling us this
like it can't be legit yeah it's like
what's the point of having secret codes
if we all know them they're not secret
until not so secret anymore but I just I
love the Queen and I love the royal
family I just I want like royal family
like joy like this forever
say no to The Bachelor like I'm really
intrigued with like the intricacies of
the like logistics of being a royal okay
but I feel like I know all the
intricacies of The Bachelor by now every
time we have someone on that's all we
ask about and I think at the end of the
day it's like they all fly coach is a
warrior expert yeah but like they only
fly private the they have their own
plane the Royals yeah of course take Air
Force One Queen stock do they all fly it
together well if they're going on a
family trip but I don't think they're
open do you think they have more than
one plane like well I think the Queen
doesn't fly that often so like I'm sure
you know Charles and William can take
the plane yeah I think who do you think
is like first access the Queen really I
think William Jimmy Williams the most
important no I feel like he's gonna be a
great leader like I'm really excited
about it I know but like we have to wait
so long because like even after the
Queen Adobe Charles and like with modern
medicine like who knows and then William
will be king when he's 60
will we be like yeah well he will have
was like literally one strand of hair
yeah no we'll be bald like when I see
pictures of him when he's younger it
makes me really sad
yeah you saw that meme like the greatest
British tragedy I still think he's a
handsome man
no me too and I think that like if I had
to choose between marrying will and will
or Harry I would choose well and us
like we don't I don't want a hot King no
I want a king his priorities would be
out of whack totally you know like I
need a humbled King ya husband he's
really like a true husband yeah so and I
don't know he's still hot he's not like
so hot and I mean he just seems more
ground and isolates priorities in order
I would much prefer will over Harry he's
a prince
that's hot and Harry look [ __ ] around
for so long he definitely has like
Kennedy or something no he doesn't he's
suddenly smart girls with comitia he's
definitely smart he's definitely like
uses production ok next story we have
another Royal Wedding story that's just
an interesting tidbit over the night
George Clooney serves shots of his
tequila at the Royal Wedding like quick
Hawking for one second but there were so
many details I came out about the after
party interest elbow was the DJ oh cool
he's out what does he do that and Serena
Williams and George Clooney like we're
ripping shots Serena Williams in George
Clooney meat that's great ok so George
Clooney jumped behind the bar and hocked
his billion-dollar booze brand at the
royal wedding reception the star who
would tend the nuptials with wife Amal
Clooney was serving up shots of his cos
amigos tequila at the event and was also
spotted whisking the bride away for a
dance during the party wait George
Clooney had a dance with Megan Marco I
wonder if a mile had a dance with Prince
Harry for sure wow what a foursome I
just I love details um yeah so that
sounds really [ __ ] fun and I'm
obsessed with the the success story of
custom egos it's wildly interesting it's
wildly interesting it's wildly
successful and I don't drink tequila but
it's apparently it's wildly good and
it's like I drink it it's spent on it's
like the tea dose of to keep like you
know same level no it's very expensive
it's like over $50 a bottle is like 25
like cots amigos is just another good
expensive tequila it's like yesterday
thrown yeah it's it's it's up there I
thought it was like affordable
no and the interesting thing about it
it's like all these tequila brands are
like so old like Don Julio like they've
been around forever
so like for a brand new brand to come
and be as popular it's like really
impressive that is impressive and I'm
equally impressed by Tito's no they
don't those isn't Tito's his down is
incredible and they don't have like the
celebrity they don't have endorsers you
know
it's so popular because it's so cheap
and it's just as good and it's
gluten-free and it's made in America
it's making American jobs and me yeah
it's wild it's crazy how it really like
took over and it's like even like older
people order it yes which is great
because they're so like City College
drew but it also started a first time I
had it was because they meant those
enormous jugs yeah and it came in like a
paper bag and I was like we're gonna
drink like potato vodka yeah literally
and it was tasty it's like no like what
good matka was in college I would just
drink anything why are they delicious
well it's wildly successful and wildly
it's not ugly delicious um this just
sounds so fun I never want like the the
debris of the royal wedding to stop
being thrown at me I totally agree we
need to get like someone on who was
there to do just bite you did he pee oh
okay okay it's something dead in his
mouth I thought he peed oh my god I was
like Larry gonna be so Maris to my son I
thought that he it's what was it a
thumbtack he's had that in this month
before excited he seems fine he's he's
literally insane yeah no he lives on the
edge at ticks
I'll take him though he's I wonder if I
wonder like who was the drunkest person
at the party
see how morning I was thinking like you
don't really drink at the Royal Wedding
like you can you be such an
embarrassment well I wonder like does
the Queen obviously doesn't say the
whole time like maybe the party doesn't
start til the team leaves yeah yeah the
party don't start til he walks out don't
make it pop Megan throw your sneakers up
they should teach me Megan was a tape
about who a change into see her is
definitely not
I want oh what we did see her I feel
like another Emily in it cuz her hand
was way too long
she would have been dragging I think
another royal rule is like you're not
allowed to wear flats do you agree or no
I don't know we should we should see if
Kate's ever been in spotted wearing
flats also speaking of a royal expert he
does have a royal expert anytime she say
so it says something I don't believe her
no she's a fraud she makes [ __ ] what's
her name Melanie Brown Melanie she has
gotten so far just because of her accent
that's crazy has put her on every are
you getting Theo eating his you shed
Theo was just
so no is not a world expert like the
only people who are people who have
worked in the household like private
second they're not allowed to talk and
biographers like anyone whose story yeah
that's why the crown is like just it's
so exciting because like they use real
documents like get this plot mm-hm so
whenever the time comes for Meghan like
we'll know what was going on but how
much time are by how much time moves by
in the crown like what okay we see Megan
Marco in 30 seasons no I think honestly
in maybe three years
oh really yeah because they just
switched out the cast for this next
season of like so no longer Claire Foy
has them clean anymore like someone 20
years older than her so the Queen's now
gonna be in her 40s it's gonna be like
the Diana era coming up soon oh so I
should totally start watching hands yeah
cuz that's when it starts to get good
like it so it's definitely slow but it's
really interesting and I just feel like
I know so much about yeah about the
Queen about the Queen and I love her and
I feel like I know so much like and now
I understand why it's such a big deal
that megan michael is a divorce right
no I'm really trying to like be smarter
do you know Damian and I think starting
with the royal family it's like
animating and its historic I'll watch it
if you watch planet earth you have to
watch it at night in the dark it's
unbelievable the cameras that BBC has
they literally plant camera they have a
65 inch TV so it'll look great for me
okay so I don't know if anyone cares but
I think I've decided to take the
apartment and a jack is gonna come see
it with me today at 2 o'clock
but from everything you told me it
sounds like the right decision because
you want to know why is I I I'm still
continuously Wow Tigs yeah what's wrong
do you have something to say do you
maybe he wants me to take the apartment
once he or he doesn't the oak bark if I
shouldn't take the apartment he wants it
anyone said Wow what's that
if that's not a sign I don't know
whether go sign sign here
I'm still waiting to be approved so all
of this could be just you know hearsay
your credit or yeah 675 I'm proud of my
credit score 675 ones imagine if your
credit score was 117 I definitely be so
excited take scream okay we have our
fifth and final story which is a little
different than what we usually report on
just because like I find this wildly oh
my god and I don't think I'll ever get
over this story never and
are gonna have to because the Malaysia
Airlines flight 370 the search is coming
to an end
this is actually the first time we've
reported a story from the Irish Times
that is the source on this one the
Malaysian Minister announces conclusion
of our operation to locate the missing
clean which is so tragic like it's like
I feel two ways I'm like what you're
just gonna abandon like literally the
300 people who just randomly went
missing but also it's like how many
resources can you can you use on
something that's never going to be found
also so many different like countries
have contributed to this and different
investigation like companies so it's not
be found where how do you lose up where
the [ __ ] is that Malaysian plane like do
you think we'll ever find out or is this
like Amelia Earhart no this is like a
thing we never find out like it's an
eighth wonder but like I get that the
ocean is super big and like it's
possible that we don't find it but like
how does literally like a huge like
plane just like disappear I don't know
and like we never even found out what
happened and they did find like pieces
of debris like they found seats because
the seats float okay so it's like it's
somewhere unless like someone's just
like I'm like of the conspiracy now like
someone took it and like landed it in
their country and like and those people
are like dead or like hostages but then
the point of a hostages its to get what
you want to live you would have to tell
someone if you took them no it's just
like planes just don't disappear so I
like refused to believe that this is the
end I know if you like me then we're
like 50 years old doing this show we'll
report a story that's like they found
the plane I really hope we're not doing
the show when we're 50 look I'm like you
know escalate in some way yeah or just
like give up yeah I hope we know when to
fold them you got to know we're like a
language able them I would say it would
do this show for like five years
oh my god it's so wrong okay they're
gonna say that's a short I'm like so no
in the next five years if we make like
absolutely no improvements like no one
wants to like sponsor or no one wants to
put us on TV like nothing radio but
you're gonna give it five years for that
yeah that's so wrong I know it's only
been two months I know what it feels
but it's really been it's been a year
yeah so four years no no because we
started fresh five years
years you guys have five years to make
the show something notable or else I'm
done okay wow that's so long I'm gonna
be 30 perfect and then after 30 it's
like she's a web show you know I mean
totally you can't be like Teri Hatcher
has a web show and it's like so sad
that's really sad okay so the story is
that the latest search for Malaysia
flight 370 will end next week says
Malaysia's new Transport Minister
Malaysia has signed a quote no cure no
fee agreement with texas-based ocean
infinity in January to resume the hunt
for the plane a year after the official
search in the southern Indian Ocean by
Australia Malaysia and China was called
off Transport Minister Anthony Lok said
that the latest search was due to end in
April but was extended twice until May
29th at ocean infinity's request he said
the government will decide its next its
next course of action next week the
Malaysia Airlines plane vanished on
March 8 2014 while flying from Kuala
Lumpur to Beijing with 239 people on
board it's just like could there be a
worse PR for Malaysia air I'm surprised
that they haven't gone under there
absolutely the second flight of no but
that was Malaysia - the one that was
shot down but by the Russians or the in
over the Ukraine I think it was the
Russians I did it I'm so confused by
Russia oh my god it's crazy but they're
still afloat Malaysia right like hell in
their right mind would fly Malaysia it's
like there are people still people who
are flying Southwest you know like the
woman got sucked out no but then you
know a second plane had the same thing
shrapnel flew through the window but no
one got sucked out and I'm pretty sure
everyone was okay no like I'm like never
flying again and if I am I'm only gonna
find out so they're the only people who
are having problems now with all this
stuff like I used to just like book like
now I'm really thinking through every
trip that I'm taking like is this
visible light is it worth my life is it
worth my life so it's sad that that's
the state that we live in no it's it's
so sad but and then you also have to
think about it like the amount of planes
that fly and also like shipping planes
how many planes are in the sky every
single the FedEx like yes I want to fly
FedEx you know jargon trust me you do
dumb right have you called cargo have
you heard of a seats they just throw
boxes in about have you heard of a FedEx
clean yeah with shrapnel with what
shrapnel shrapnel shrapnel what is that
that's what happened that Southwest
where the shrapnel flew through shrapnel
shrapnel
SHR AP NOL shrapnel September something
no it's just debris shrapnel why are you
saying that like it's a common thing
everyone should know Cheryl it's like
when there's like a bomb or something
like the shrapnel it's what kills people
shrapnel just give me a second okay
castaway was a FedEx plane apparently oh
really
I guess haven't seen a movie in so long
I live irrational Oh Wilson fragments of
a bombshell or other objects thrown out
by an explosion literally everything I
just said
well I'm incredibly impressed thank you
for a shell containing bullets or pieces
of metal time to burst out sort of
impact Wow
and so that's also what exploded from
the engine on Southwest and then the
shrapnel flew through very cool okay so
I take it back I do not want to fight
FedEx because that's what the Castaway
playing I guess he was a FedEx
plane driver I never saw Castro yes you
did Wilson but I know well said I like
having to turn on cast wait for one
second and it's at like the most iconic
scene where the volleyball rolls away oh
and it's like you hear all about Wilson
your whole life and then you've come to
find out Wilson as a [ __ ] volleyball
with like hair well sir it's such a sad
movie imagine being friends with a
volleyball that's the real tragedy that
is but like you know desperate times
nobody ways I do you want to keep
talking I'm just like so afraid to be
like stranded on an island you know yeah
like anytime I go anywhere what would be
the situation where you alone would be
no I don't know but like the the idea of
like you know how people like go on
hikes and like crazy remote areas and
like get off track and they literally
die because there's no cell service they
can't find them like that is my worst
nightmare so anywhere anytime I go
somewhere even like remotely desolate
I'd like have to pack like like I'm
never coming back you know yeah but now
that I felt that way when we took the
jet skis to the shipwreck like we were
so far out yes and like no when we went
to Utah we were like an hour from the
airport and I was thinking I'm like
we're definitely gonna be like with no
woods I'm like this is somewhat
dangerous no only when we were like
snowmobiling that's we're like on our
own Oh exactly so we meant we went
snowmobiling and our tour guide when we
were in Utah like a loved us and he was
like we got so good at it he like took
us like the expert level we're like
there was no track he's just like fresh
snow and like you never know what's
underneath the snow it could be like a
river and it could be like really deep
so we were you go in a line and the the
guy was at the front and we're literally
in the scariest like we're on a cliff
and it's like five o'clock it's like
about to be dark so it's like we're
ready to go home it was like scary all
of a sudden I turn around Margo and
Olivia aren't behind us so we stay there
and the tour guide that goes and finds
them and thank God he found them they
were just stuck like in a thing but like
if they had taken a wrong turn and we
were literally like miles from home like
and it was about to get dark and there's
no cell service like that was really
scary yeah and you were like taking
selfies and I was like I don't think you
understand the gravity of the situation
your sister's going south he's like when
I got into a car crash in Atlantic Beach
and you were taking selfies okay you
didn't get into a car crash she got into
like she tapped someone in the parking
lot but it was bad because there's a
rental car and I sideswiped the car it
wasn't a tap thank god the woman
couldn't have cared less about her car
she literally wiped her car it wasn't
fine for us yeah um so I'm gonna ask if
you went to a super stranded on an
island what would you need and like
obviously would want your phone and
stuff but like what would get you
through that you could bring no no but
like you can't have your phone or it
doesn't have service no phone no iPad no
computer but I have the necessities of
like water and food sure like yeah
somebody to keep me entertained yeah
something to keep you entertained to you
know you would feed him yeah and I love
it wow you guys would be so happy and I
wouldn't feel like so alone yeah what
are you I don't know what I don't know
what keeps me entertained other than
like TV like a book I guess nobody would
finish he needs like a really dynamic
book that if you keep rereading it like
the art of war like there's more meaning
behind holy like it's a book you can
read a thousand times and still learn a
thing or like absolutely a book I'm
survival oh yeah that's good too like
they have your device for dummies Bear
Grylls woman vs. wild
sure whatever have it survivor expedited
what do one that I probably just want
like a bunch of makeup and like it
really good it made me go oh my god
that's like the last thing I would want
to be so sweaty try like new stuff like
wind at
like I would just get so good I would be
some who knew I it's just like it's fun
like me sitting and doing my makeup like
it's fun for me yeah so like I could
just and then I could come back and be
like a big YouTube star I'm really
excited to have lunch I'm so hungry
okay we got to get to G our toasters
because there's people out here there's
people out here who need our help sister
yeah are you ready thing to do are you
ready to help them so ready okay
first story is called money pit Wow I
have a pit before just cuz my stomach
hurts okay lately I have been going out
with friends lately I have been going
out with friends have been the one stuck
with the bill okay that was your problem
I realize that I might be the one in the
group with a better paying job but I
feel as if sometimes I'm taken advantage
of
I'd like to treat people and I would
never want my friends to struggle but
sometimes I feel as if there's now an
expectation that I will pay your being
walked all over whether it is the
alcohol or the lift home I'm always the
one to take out a card I think the thing
that annoys me the most is no one ever
offers to pitch in or asks what they owe
I truly hate asking for money and if
this situation is ever reversed I go out
of my way to make sure my return portion
is paid how can I ask for money without
upsetting my friends you don't ask for
money you just stop paying mm-hmm like
like when you don't have to go and ask
people for venmo requests if you're not
the one that they need to request and
also like if you guys are going into a
liquor store like wait in the car yeah
just like start to be that person who
sits in the front the cab so like they
don't access to the credit card machine
no and yeah just like or you're in the
back of the store like on a phone call
you start guys they're absurd out sorry
like just stop paying for stuff this is
like an episode of friend and it's like
I get the feeling I know that feeling
when you're like I'll send by the
register and everyone's being like a
freak about you pulling out their money
so just like it's so much easier to pay
them to deal with that but don't be
around don't be in that situation like
just remove yourself I'd rather feel
uncomfortable about who's gonna pay then
uncomfortable trying to get people to
pay me back right and if your friends
are always like asking either don't
either pay when you pay and don't pay
your friends back when they pay so what
if they're saying they owe you money
then come back with a list of things
that yes thank you more tips or if
they're making you pay for the things
that they pay for it didn't make them
pay for the things that you pay for it
then we'll request them if you have to
even though that's really petty and it's
the easy way to lose friends and then
everyone will talk about you behind your
back and like set reminders for the for
the notifications like when they don't
pay right but be like you just need to
like pretend like you're busy and stop
paying for stuff this is like an episode
of Friends where three of them are like
really in like good jobs and three of
them like Phoebe's like a part-time
masseuse Joey's an out-of-work actor and
Phoebe and Rachel's the waitress and the
go to like fancy dinners getting
defensive gifts for everyone fancy shows
and they're like we can literally can't
do it anywhere in those like such an
awkward episode same thing so what was
the solution well then they were like
okay we'll just pay the further tickets
for you and like we want to be a charity
case and they were being annoying it's
like okay so like decide you don't want
to pay or you want to pay figure it out
why should they stop having a good time
cuz you're a waitress totally yes so
just like played on you're not there
you're in the bathroom sorry honestly I
forgot my wallet at home
playing dumb is the key to success in
life ignorant is bliss I don't know who
made it up that ignorance is not blessed
but ignorance is the essence of less
totally cuz then like once you know like
you have a bit of course I like honestly
I'm ignorant when it comes to a lot of
stuff and like it's a true pleasure okay
next story I hope that was helpful just
like say no be ignorant
say no to life yeah cheating cousin this
past weekend I went to the beach with my
husband and we ran into my cousin's wife
she was blackout drunk when we got there
but was very happy to see us
we met of her a few of her friends and
had a few drinks at the beach bar then
we went to a super shady bar after
meeting with them and she brought a guy
friend along when we were dancing I
noticed my cousin's wife and the guy
getting very close next thing I know she
disappeared I went around the other side
of the bar to find them making out I was
so shook I had a pin and told my husband
we had to leave I don't know what to do
should I call my cousin's wife and tell
her what I saw I want to tell my cousin
but he's currently deployed so I have no
contact with him oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this
guy's out here letting his life on the
line and you're slutting it up at the
beach oh my goodness I might I'll tell
him I was literally as you were reading
it I was like tell the cousin your
loyalties lie with the cousin do not
call the cousin he has enough on his
plate go tell the wife be like [ __ ] I
saw you take care of it when you get
home and I'll [ __ ] like a literally I'll
[ __ ] you up
but yeah I do not tell the husband while
he's deployed like there's nothing you
can do about it then you just give him a
huge pit on top of like an Iraqi sized
pit having to defend the whole country
oh my god that's horrifying I think I
would mention that you were also like -
she's blackout drunk maybe this is not
like a regular it should be like hey
Sally
I saw you I'm not gonna tell my husband
because he's busy saving our lives you
need to tell him and you must stop right
now or like I'm terribly gonna she
you taking a picture no but like maybe
she might not even know that she did it
right
talk to the girl yeah and if you like
like it depends how you relate what you
really think of her like if you think
she's a nice girl I'm like this was just
like a fluke she obviously misses her
husband she got too drunk in the beach
and then she was not responsible for her
actions just you know handle her kindly
if you think she's a sleuth a chest
about if you think she's a sleuth and
sheep's clothing get rid of her
yeah but like it's obviously delicate
she definitely misses her husband so
much I got him being deployed like
change the whole story for me I was
literally about to be like what are you
talking about this is the dumbest steer
toeses ever obviously tell the husband
tell the cousin okay
next story bridezilla sister question
mark she doesn't even know he doesn't
know I'm so right
no no cuz you're not a bride yet you
haven't done anything yeah and once we
start planning I'm doing said I'm just
not bothering you with it oh please I'm
not I don't believe in the word
bridezilla anymore it's a judgmental
term and it's offensive I just know that
like I'm not a bridezilla they come out
up write anything sure that's true cuz
you're gonna start yes chillin I'm a
chiller go my sister is getting married
in September and I'm so happy for her I
never pegged her as being the bridezilla
type though and here we are
she's so indecisive about what she wants
and is complaining about money but I'm
being a supportive sister and helping in
a way and any way I can
I'm even buying the wedding cake for her
here's where it gets a little sticky
though I love to model and was asked to
do a mock wedding photo shoot with my
boyfriend to promote local vendors he
was a good sport and we went ahead with
it when my sister found out we were
planning on doing this she was so upset
with me I respectfully agreed to not
personally post-editing up the photos
myself in the wedding dress until after
her wedding well my feet wedding day
came and it was so much fun I posted a
few photos of the day just the venue
flowers and makeup my sister immediately
texted me instead of quote
you had to known that by posting this
people would click on the people you
linked right I have people ask me why
you're in a wedding dress when no one
when I'm the one getting married I was
so taken aback and just deleted the post
am I in the wrong here should I feel bad
about my decisions or is she just being
a bridezilla no your sisters out of
control that's the dumbest thing I've
ever heard the whole story is weird am i
taking wedding photos with your
boyfriend it's bad karma that is bad
karma but if she lectures she's got a
modeling jobs on her vault
but like with her boyfriend that's
whatever they're taking wedding photos
she's singing buddy if he was with a
random model and this girl's a model
okay no one's like I show it something a
weird thing for you to do but it's also
weird as hell for your sister to give a
shred of a [ __ ] I know how far out when
is her wedding versus when these
pictures were no I don't know her
weddings in September that's something I
marry it was a month before she's not
even engaged it's modeling it's not
modeling when it's your boyfriend like
no but she's doing it as like as it's an
advertisement it's a weird story for
sure I think the sister being that is
beyond strange the sister shouldn't be
mad but like you posting wedding
pictures with your boyfriend
let's no you shouldn't have posted it
but she liked the way that she looked I
can totally understand that I just think
it's like it's when it's been karma it's
like trying on a wedding dress take mine
it's a chimera um but no she shouldn't
be really mad about that that's a weird
dude testers do we have one more that's
it I'm glad we ended our week and our
dear testers segment on the strangest
I'm such a weird no no you're not
finishing it because we cannot detect
that I got Jackie to watch for the
kissing booth another list of things I
totally started to kissing booth Joe
actually didn't Margo start it yes but
she doesn't count Jackie what did you
think oh it was it was so sweet it was
so it was so good it was so like such a
rollercoaster of emotion and I have a
lot of thoughts on the casting and two
of them and the hair and the hair you
said she doesn't brush her hair once
that's not true she brushed her hair a
few times and towards like she was act
and I know you're gonna disagree with me
but I think she was like the perfect
cast for the role because she's a type
of girl is like she is she's beautiful
but then she also like sometimes just
looks like a hot mess ninth grader and
she really sold that part of like yes
I'm not sure about her of like you know
she doesn't realize how pretty she is
but like it also makes sense like if you
look at Joey Kings Instagram like she's
absolutely beautiful and like Noah Flynn
saw that in her and like I liked that
aspect the moments where she was
supposed to be beautiful like the prom
dress it's just that was just tacky but
like she is so pretty and like their
height difference was so cute no he's so
hot I can't move that they're dating in
real life it makes it so much about it
makes it so much better also they film
this movie like
Oh city maybe shot back here in South
Africa and then once Margaret told me
that the movie was filmed in South
Africa now I watch her back home I go
that's totally South Africa like had to
be not no oh really
it looks nothing like la oh my god
that's so funny but what was I gonna say
about her also her body is amazing she
kept taking her clothes have a nice I
know totally it was like what I liked
about the movie and this is what I was
saying to Darrin on Friday it's like
they didn't like cut corners when it
comes to like awkward things in high
school like they drink some kids smoke
weed they have sex and like when they
weren't drinking like one that's what
happens at high school parties I feel
like most movies like don't know what
happens at a high school party cuz they
were never invited to them yeah but like
that's a high school party like yeah
yeah and they just go in the pool yeah
and you take your shirt off
yeah if you're that that's like the
essence of high school no totally and
like when they had that party on the
beach and they're like just all getting
drunk oh thanks a lot of inciting Lipka
that's what you do when you're a kid and
no they had like a resident high
schooler being like what school totally
and they like but what would you do if
you had a beach party and she like threw
the party no and it was animate I wanted
to be at that party here are a few
things that bothered me okay
just like it didn't really make sense
that Lea Flynn would be like a nerd and
that no one would like him because he's
not he's hot he was King so the two of
them look so much alike I know they
found really good at when he was wearing
them like there was a couple scenes and
in the beginning of the movie I didn't
know who I was to second which is
perfect because her brothers so it
didn't really make sense that he would
be a nerd and that OMG girl wouldn't
like it because like his brothers the
coolest guy in school and he was hot and
he had a cool car like no no but it
didn't actually make sense because the
girl that he wound up being with like
most important was pretty and like just
a normal girl but an OMG girl wants to
be with no I'm saying she thinks she's
that cool you know who I thought was hot
the guy with the long curly hair who
grabbed her ass in the parking lot he
was hot it was like no high schooler
looks like that he was absolutely huge
but I thought he was hot but there was
also like a weird dynamic with like the
brother like him being like them being
like almost like a family yeah and then
like they're in love to know when she
goes to the party at his house and he's
making out with that girl and then the
girl it shoves out and he's like she's
important to me I was like yes she is
I need 20 Vega I'm like I literally
loved it I loved l like man-eaters I was
like come on like brush your hair yes
then I like to eat him bother me and
like she was just like so cute and
naturally beautiful and like 11th
graders look like that yes that's 11th
grader and I appreciated that
so Jacob oh lordy who plays Noah and now
he has his haircut and he looks so hot
yeah the hair he was rocking in the
movie like his to Justin but it's very
high 2011 it's very high school I guess
oh but this was a brother like he was
out of control [ __ ] like such a month
he could tell his friend is obviously
upset like get your friendship is never
gonna be the same if your friend is
always gonna resent you for like taking
away the love of her life so like you
need to nut up and eventually he did but
like I took him away too long
yeah but the scene when he when he saw
his brother say to l-like I love you in
front of everyone or whatever and he
still didn't give it up at the prom that
was funny because the prawns gone on too
much Japanese same and wait the when
they finally starts a date like under
the radar and they have that montage to
that song um I don't remember was like
an amazing song do you know what it is I
don't know the song when I'm talking the
montage like it was a beautiful night it
was long and it was long it was like the
real religion he said he loves her I'm
like I knew that was coming in like a
movie dating in movies when they do the
montages like it's usually the best part
of the movie whether it's like a
makeover or it's like a love thing like
they make the montage it's so short and
it's like that's the best part of the
movie that montage is like five minutes
long and it's so damn cute when they're
like sneaking around in school and then
they run to the beach and he puts a
helmet on her like I was like I learned
I've watched out 100 times because it's
a long montage know anything they've
done everything together like they
learned how to ride a motorcycle they go
to the beach they talk they eat they go
on adventure it's like they have a real
relationship so she would have been
driving the motorcycle and we're like
how does she know how to drive right and
as opposed like just her go I know this
hasn't like them [ __ ] every day yeah
what probably is what they did to after
they did activities oh my god and then
when when they were [ __ ] at her house
and Lee was there and she was like he
was like I heard moaning and she's like
oh yeah I was born that's funny
that was honey I'm like Molly Ringwald I
can't my god oh so elite wait the Molly
Ringwald of it all is the best part I
love how she's really leaning into like
the mom actress on all teenybopper shows
totally and when when she's like a
sterically crying in her house and
someone comes over and you think it's
gonna be Lee or Noah and it's the mom it
was like so sweet so sweet uh also the
dad was weird
the dad was weird he like didn't really
have a part why did she not have to have
but why did she have to not have a mom
because that's a Disney it wouldn't have
been like a Disney like right adult
movie monologue yeah I guess it was just
like and it was so raunchy to like she
was oh he's like getting naked and like
and the even the kissing booth part
itself it was like really like wild
provocative like everyone's just kissing
millions of people in there like it
meant something it meant by the way
nothing but right now and then everyone
acting like they had like banana
recreation of the kissing with that prom
like I don't think the kissing booth
have meant as much to everyone as it did
just to L do you know what I mean yeah
but like it didn't even it only meant
something to l-like because of Jacob but
like Nolan but if Noah hadn't kissed her
like they were still gonna act like the
kissing booth meant something right
because he movement nothing
yeah chance now yeah no totally I need
to watch it again it's so good I'm like
the fact that that's the name of the
movie like it should be called it was
like they were just trying to make the
kissing booth important when like it
could have been called to anything else
it had nothing to do with the kissing
and also I'm so glad I I never saw a
trailer for the movie I didn't even see
the cover where it's like she has to be
there because so I didn't know if she
was gonna end up with Lee or know what
when she had saying no it was cute like
growing up like I didn't know and would
know what was like you're like a little
a sister like I was like oh this he
doesn't like her later I had no clue
where the movie was going and I loved
that
Jackie same and like I need a sequel
does she go to Harvard like what happens
she has to go to Harvard that was also
just like a little unrealistic that he
was always getting in trouble go to the
principal's office
but he also got into Harvard you don't
get to do here's the thing though I was
trying to think of like what the sequel
could be about and there's no way that
it could be good because like either
their relationship is gonna be
challenged which like no one wants to
see no or their relationships gonna be
solid and like just boring while they're
do each doing challenges in their own
life of their relationship like this is
the only way it could be no totally I
just want to know it's a little bit more
of like a decisive ending yeah well she
got a motorcycle so that cool so she
doesn't have to get a ride from Lee the
house that they live in I know I just
like about Molly Ringwald do for a
living I think it's more than a dad and
I just like thanks rich
totally well she's always at home doing
laundry she could do both totally
totally listen II knew it all that's
true I'm sorry I'm sorry as I said that
I'm sorry I'm very sorry I'm running
sorry boy yeah I'm sorry yeah okay you
guys that's our last show of the week
thank you guys so much for tuning in
this is the
we go live Monday through Friday except
this week Monday through Wednesday at
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we go live on
Facebook's to make sure you like us we
go live on YouTube so make sure you
subscribe to us and then we're also
available in the podcast or so they
leave a subscription and a review about
how gorgeous and stunning we are make
sure to keep up with girl with no job
and jackieo problems on Instagram this
weekend I'll be hosting my hundred K
celebratory posts either tonight or
tomorrow I just had to get my lay people
video I'm sorry it's so sad I know I did
a poll I was ok I wrote it was you vote
nudies of course maybe I mean that's
never gonna happen plus it's time with
people on know you're gonna be a married
woman it's a nice no we love you guys I
hope you have an amazing Memorial Day
weekend and make lots of memories bye
what are you supposed to do on Memorial
Day weekend barbecue